- OKAY,
LET'S GET THIS THING GOING.
EVERYBODY TAKE A SEAT.
WE GOT TO HAVE
MORE MEETINGS, HOMES,
'CAUSE I'M TELLING YOU, MAN,
WE GOT TO GET ORGANIZED.
[sighs]
[police sirens in the distance]
CARLITO AIN'T GOT A SEAT, MAN.
SOMEONE GET HIM A CHAIR.
- NO, I'M COOL.
- NO, DUDE, GET HIM A CHAIR,
HOMES.
- I'M GONNA SIT GANGSTER.
- BUT, CARLITO, IT DOESN'T LOOK
LIKE IT'S COMFORTABLE, MAN.
WHY DON'T YOU
JUST SIT IN THE CHAIR?
- I NEVER SIT
IN NO CHAIR, ESE.
MM-MMM.
YOU NEVER, EVER GON' CATCH ME
SITTING IN NO CHAIRS.
- HEY, ESE, YOU KNOW THAT
THAT'S LOCO, RIGHT?
- NO, MAN.
[scoffs]
- IT'S COOL, CARLITO.
NO ONE'S GONNA THINK
YOU'RE SOFT
IF YOU SIT IN A CHAIR, HOMES.
- YEAH, YEAH.
- WE'RE ALL SITTING IN CHAIRS.
- RIGHT.
- BUNCH OF BITCH-ASS CULEROS.
- QUE?
- I DON'T HAVE NO TIME
TO SIT IN NO [bleep] CHAIR.
- OKAY.
NOW THAT WE'RE ALL HERE--
YOU KNOW WHAT?
BUT WHY, THOUGH?
LIKE, IT DON'T MAKE NO SENSE
FOR YOU TO SET YOURSELF UP
WITH A RULE LIKE THAT.
- NO, IT'S, LIKE, LIMITING.
- YEAH, LIMITING.
- LIMITING.
- I MEAN, SOMETIMES,
PEOPLE SIT IN CHAIRS.
- MAN, [bleep] ALL OF YOU GUYS
WITH YOUR BITCH-ASS CHAIRS.
[wood cracks]
- THERE.
- [scoffs]
- OKAY, CARLITO, QUIT PLAYING
AND SIT IN THE CHAIR, PENDEJO.
- NO.
- CARLITO,
WE HAVE TO HAVE THIS MEETING
NOW, ESE. GET UP!
- I'M GOOD RIGHT HERE, MAN.
- YOU KNOW--
- I'M CHILLING.
GO AHEAD WITH YOUR MEETING.
- OKAY, BUT YOU KNOW
IT'S GOING TO BE WEIRD.
YOU DON'T CARE
THAT IT'S GOING TO BE WEIRD?
- WEIRD FOR YOU, MAYBE.
- HE DOESN'T CARE.
OKAY.
OKAY, HOMIES,
SO THIS IS WHAT WE HAVE TO DO,
LIKE, WE GOT TO SELL
MORE DRUGS...
- [groaning]
- AND WE GOT TO MAKE
MORE CRIMES HAPPEN.
ROBERTO, WHERE ARE WE--
- [groaning]
- CARLITO,
YOU'RE BLEEDING, ESE!
- [grunts]
WHO CARES, MAN?
[winces]
- YO, WHOA!
YOU JUST GOT SHANKED, MAN!
WE GOT TO PULL THAT OUT!
- LEAVE IT!
I'M CHILLING, HOMES.
I DON'T CARE
ABOUT THAT STUPID SHANK.
[groaning]
[exhales]
- CARLITO.
CARLITO, WAKE UP, MAN!
[radio chatter]
- HEY,
DON'T EVEN BOTHER, ESE.
- WHAT?
[screams]
OH, DIOS MIO!
- I DON'T NEED
THOSE DEFIBRILLATORS.
I DON'T EVEN WANT TO COME BACK
TO LIFE, HOMES.
- CARLITO,
GO BACK INTO YOUR BODY.
- MY BODY'S STUPID, HOMES.
- WHAT?
- I'M FINE RIGHT HERE
ON THE SPIRIT PLANE.
LIFE IS FOR PUSSIES.
[heavenly singing]
- CARLITO.
CARLITO, GO TO THE LIGHT.
- NAH, I'M GOOD, MAN.
- CARLITO,
THAT'S HEAVEN, MAN.
- I DON'T NEED TO GO
TO HEAVEN, HOMES.
HEAVEN IS FOR PUSSIES.
- OH, BOY.